yeah and this is a joint work with Anna
Carlin who's here and who foo who is
right over there okay so I'm going to
talk about mechanism design so let's
start with the standard model for
mechanism design there's a cellar
offering goods or services and for most
of this talk I'm going to assume that
the seller has one item to sell and
there are buyers with known values that
arrived and are interested in buying
this item and we want to design an
auction or mechanism for this they're
the seller which takes in as input the
buyers values and returns an allocation
of the item or items and also a price to
charge each buyer and our goal for this
talk is to maximize the sellers revenue
okay and typically we assume in the
setting that the seller has some vision
information about the buyers so he knows
the distribution from which the values
are drawn and can use this in designing
an auction okay now in many realistic
settings this model is actually not
completely relevant and I like to think
of the situation where there's a house
for sale and you know buyers arrive and
then they you know look at the house
they get the you know get it inspected
and so on and they use all of this
information to you know get the best
idea they can about their own value but
they might not know their own value
perfectly this is some function of what
they observe and also some function of
what other people observe okay and I'm
going to get a call this model the
interdependent values setting and let me
define this sort of model precisely this
formalization is to do to Milgram and
whether so here each buyer now obtains
some signal about his true value for the
item
under seal and these signals are drawn
from some joint distribution they could
be correlated or not and then the the
value of a buyer is a function of all of
these signals okay and for most of the
stock I'm going to assume that this is a
function of this simple additive form
much of the work in this area in fact
applies specifically to this format but
in fact our results will apply a little
more generally so I'll talk about that
later but let's assume that this value
let's assume for now that it's some
additive function that depends on each
of these signals in some manner okay and
also just as a sanity check we're going
to assume that the signal is positively
correlated with the values of VI is a
non decreasing function of the agents
own signal okay and the question we want
to ask is so now the informational e the
setting is a little bit different and we
want to ask well what's how do we design
a mechanism for the sort of setting okay
now note that you know one primary
difference between this setting and what
we saw before is that the buyer starts
out with some limited information about
his own value and through the course of
the mechanism might learn more and more
and you know update what he knows about
his own value depending on what he
learns about other people during the
mechanism so there's a question of what
we mean by incentive compatibility in
this context and we're going to use of
the strongest possible version of inside
of compatibility which is exposed
incentive compatibility will say that
the buyer is satisfied reporting his
information even after he has observed
everything there is to observe about
other people's signals yeah you're
assuming the signal is a real number is
that without loss of generality that is
not without loss of generality but we
will assume that so we're talking about
you know every agent being a single
parameter agent so they're so for most
of the talk we will talk about there
being a single item for sale in which
case it it sort of makes sense that the
signal captures the buyers best
information at the beginning of the
mechanism about his own value that is
multi-dimensional in something yeah but
here we will assume that the signal is
single dimensional and I don't think
that's without loss of generality so we
will use the concept of exposed I see
and in this talk I want to ask the
question of how you maximize revenue in
the setting and we will present an
approximately optimal mechanism for this
problem okay so before we talk about
revenue let's try to understand what
happens when you're trying to maximize
welfare just to get a hang of this
setting so here's a so we're trying to
maximize welfare and in independent
value or in the standard setting where
the buyers all know their values the VCG
mechanism maximizes welfare in this
interdependent setting there's a very
natural generalization of BCG and that's
the following so you ask all the buyers
to report their signals and then use
this information to compute everyone's
values using the loan value functions
and then we allocate the item to the
buyer that has the highest value and the
question is how much should you charge
this buyer in the case of the the
private values setting we typically
charge the buyer his critical value
which is the smallest value that the
buyer would have needed to report in
order to win the item there is a natural
analog here you could talk about the
buyers critical signal which is the
smallest signal and the buyer would need
to report in order to win
item and what you could do is to charge
the value of the buyer at that critical
signal given everyone else's signals
okay it's a natural generalization of
the week reaction we will call it the
generalized Vickrey auction sorry it
says there isn't an ordering on signals
everyone reports their signals and for
the winner you could ask well what is
the smallest signal this guy needed to
report in order to win the item so there
is a problem with this auction and some
of you have already sensed that so let
me get to that so first pictorially what
is this doing so let's imagine you have
two buyers and let's say that the first
buyer is the one that has the higher
value now let me plot the values of the
two buyers as a function of the signal
of the first buyer and you know these
let's say these values they look like
these functions of s ones so I'm fixing
the second buyer signal here and our
definition of critical signal is this
point where the first guys value crosses
the second guys value okay so this is a
critical signal and this is the price
that we will sell the item add to the
first guy okay now there's an immediate
problem with this which is that it could
be the case that these value functions
cross at multiple places in which case
now you know the question is how do we
define the critical signal the Wickery
auction or generalized Vickrey auction
would want to sell to the first guy at
this signal and a signal over here but
would want to sell to the second guy if
s 1 is over here okay and if we run this
generalized week reaction it's not going
to be exposed instead of compatible so
we're going to take the easy way out
here we're going to assume that the
value functions satisfy the property
that for any s 2 if you look at the
thing that the values as a function of s
1 the only cross at one place
okay and this is a standard assumption
in all of the work on this model you
know an open question here is to think
about what to do when single crossing
doesn't hold so we will also make the
single crossing assumption yeah as it
gets larger that is a more restrictive
conditions certainly if that were the
case that would imply single crossing
but you might have single crossing even
if that's not the case everywhere
whether there is a welfare maximizing so
in the absence of this condition you're
the any auction that tries to maximize
welfare exposed is not necessary not
going to be exposed I see you could
still ask the question of what if I
wanted to maximize welfare and
expectation and that has not been
studied my knowledge well it's not going
to be so if you want to always allocate
to the person that has the highest
highest value then over here when s1 is
right here you want to allocate to the
second high the v2 here ok because v2 is
more than v1 and so if you use this as
the critical signal then this is not
truthful this is not exposed I see so
increasing the buyers signal you know
alternates who gets the item
before we move okay so we're going to
make this assumption and now we want to
move forward to revenue maximization and
ask how can we maximize the expected
revenue for this setting ok so it's
instructive to think about the special
cases of this problem that we know how
to solve so one special case is of
course the independent value setting
where every agent agents value is drawn
independently from some distribution and
every agent knows their value at the
beginning of the mechanism and in this
case most people I expect in this room
know that Myerson design a mechanism
that maximizes revenue in this case and
essentially what this mechanism does is
to express the expected revenue as a
sort of expected virtual surplus and
then maximize this virtual surplus okay
another special case that we understand
of this problem is the case where buyers
values are private so they know their
value at the beginning of the mechanism
but they're correlated drawn from some
joint distribution and in this case
ronan designed a mechanism the which
gives an approximation to the revenue
and this mechanism is essentially a sort
of victory with reserves mechanism so
it's a victory auction that sets an
appropriate result price for the agents
and then it can obtain a constant
fraction of the revenue okay so we could
start you know to in order to
approximate our general problem we could
start with one of these two approaches
and try to see how far we get and so our
first try is to you know start with the
expected revenue objective and try to
express it as a virtual surplus
and this can indeed be done and a number
of papers have tried this approach the
problem with this approach is that the
virtual value functions are not quite as
nice as in the independent setting and
in order to extract an exposed IC
mechanism from this one has to make a
number of different assumptions that the
virtual value functions have to satisfy
and the most general result in the
setting is to do Tim and involve and
they show that under you know different
assumptions one can try to maximize
virtual surplus so compute everyone's
virtual values allocate the item to the
person with the highest virtual value
and this maximizes the expected revenue
of the mechanism if it turns out to be
exposed I see okay I won't describe
these assumptions but they include for
instance symmetry across agents a
generalized version of the monotone
hazard rate assumption regularity and so
on so second try is to go with
generalized victory with reserves set
appropriately and this is also being
considered before in the paper Bhairav
garden album kohan and also a paper by
Lee and indeed this works out under
certain assumptions such as symmetry I
mentioned generalized mhr before so
under these assumptions this leads to an
approximately optimal mechanism however
once you remove these assumptions this
sort of approach can be arbitrarily bad
in general and I'm going to show an
example shortly for where this approach
fields okay so so the question is what
do we do what is the third approach that
we can follow so in the rest of the
stock I'm going to talk about Ronan's
approach for correlated values will see
why victory with reserves works in that
thing and we'll see why it fails in the
more general interdependent setting and
looking at that example will suggest a
natural modification and it turns out
that that will work generally and give
us an approximation okay so i should
thank who fool for these this nice nice
nice pictures on the next few slides so
let's think about the setting where
every buyer has private values but these
are drawn from some arbitrary joint
distribution so here are a bunch of
agents and they're competing for an item
under seal and what Ronan wants to do is
to allocate this item to the person that
has the highest value okay in this case
is this guy okay and so the question is
how much should we charge the sky for
this item okay now we want the mechanism
to be icy and so we're going to use
everything that we know about his value
except for his own report okay and so
will take everyone will ask everyone
else to report their values and we will
condition on all of these reports that
you receive and we will use these to
construct construct a conditional
distribution over this guy's value and
then we will choose the best reserve
price for this distribution and offer
the item at that price to the sky okay
and this is called the look-ahead
auction by Ronen it's essentially the
Vickrey auction with reserves okay so
let me prove to you that this auction
gets good revenue and we're going to do
this as follows so we want to relate the
revenue that this auction gets to the
optimal revenue that it could have
received so let's break up the optimal
revenue into these two components the
amount that the optimal auction gets
from everyone but the highest value
guide
among that it gets from the highest
value guy now we did the best possible
thing for the highest value guy can
given that we wanted to be exposed
instead of compatible we offer the best
possible price for the item to this guy
and so in fact this component of the
optimal revenue is no more than the
revenue that the look-ahead auction gets
but on the other hand the most Val the
most revenue we can get from these guys
is the most value for the item that any
one of them has okay and you can always
have charged this price to this highest
value guy this value is greater than
that price and so in fact this quantity
is also no more than the revenue that
the look-ahead auction gets okay and so
that proves that opt is no more than two
times are and so the local head auction
gets at least half the expected revenue
of the optimal auction okay and this
turns out to be tight again okay so what
happens when people's values are
interdependent through the signals that
they receive so I'm going to claim that
if your mechanism was only ever selling
to the highest value guy then it cannot
always guarantee a good fraction of the
optimal revenue and here is an example
for that so here is a setting where we
have a single item and two people to
buyers and the first guy is going to get
a signal that is drawn from the equal
revenue distribution normally it's this
distribution the probability that the
signal is greater than X is equal to 1
over X and this is also going to be this
guy's value ok so the
I observes his value exactly the second
guy observes nothing but his value is
just a shade lower than the first guys
value so it depends solely on the first
guy signal okay okay so what would
selling to the highest valued agent do
here well the only thing you can use is
your knowledge that his signal is drawn
from the equal revenue distribution we
don't benefit at all from seeing the
second guys signal because the second
guy doesn't get a signal and so the best
thing you can do by selling to buyer one
is to get a revenue of one dollar here
whereas what for the optimal auction do
well it's getting perfect information
about the second guys value by observing
the first guy signal so in fact it can
charge the second guy exactly his value
and still be incentive compatible and
gets unbounded revenue and expectation
okay so this is like a trivial example
in the in the setting we know exactly
what we ought to be doing but selling to
the highest value agent is not a good
idea okay and let's look at where
Ronan's argument fails so Ronan's
argument in the correlated private
values setting used the fact that we can
always extract at least as much revenue
from the highest value agent as the
second-highest guys value in the private
values setting here what happens is the
second guys value changes if the first
guys signal increases and so the first
guy signal might be out here and and the
second guys value might be much larger
than the price that we can charge at the
critical signal to the first guy so we
are giving up on all of this value by
charging the highest agent his his value
at the critical signal okay
and for this example what we ought to be
doing is to immediately eliminate buyer
one from the auction and then just sell
to buy or two and I'm going to prove to
you that this is essentially all you
need to do to Ronan's mechanism to get
approximately optimal revenue in general
so here is the mechanism that will use
in the paper we call it victory with
admission control here i call it the
Cree with random rejection I don't know
if either of those names are really good
for this but basically what we do is in
the first step we just reject any buyer
independently with some probability here
have use one half and then over the
remaining set of agents we're going to
run Ronan's mechanism which is you know
generalized victory with an optimal
reserve price and I picked the optional
reserve price looking at everyone's
recorded signals the guys that survived
the first step and also those that don't
survive the first step okay and in my
remaining seven minutes let me prove to
you that this is approximately optimal
so again let's look at the picture with
two buyers so here let's suppose that
buyer one has the higher value and the
reported signals and here again we have
the values as functions of s1 with s2
being fixed so the optimal mechanism
gets some revenue from the highest value
buyer and some revenue from the second
buyer and I'm going to think of the the
revenue from the second virus being
composed of two parts the second buyers
value at the first guys critical signal
and whatever else he gains by the first
guys signal being larger than his
critical signal okay now what is our
mechanism get well as before if it's the
case that both these two agents survived
our first random rejection step
then we do the best possible thing for
the highest value guys we get h in that
case and that takes care of this
component it also takes care of this
component just as in Ronan's argument
because we charge at least l2 to the
highest value guy and i'm going to next
prove that in the case where two
survives the first step but one doesn't
we get at least l1 okay and in that case
we can put everything together and get
for this mechanism and eight
approximation and we can adjust the
probabilities a little bit to get a
slightly improved 4.5 factor okay so let
me prove this claim now so if the second
highest value guy survives the first
step of the highest value guy doesn't
then our auction gets at least this l1
quantity and here I'm going to recall
our assumption that v2 is this sort of a
sum of functions of the signals of all
the agents okay so what's happening here
so in the second step we are
conditioning on the first guys signal
and computing the best possible price
for the second highest guy and this best
possible price is going to be at least
this component of his value g12 of s1
okay we can charge at least this much
because we know his value is at least so
much we might be charging something
higher but note that this component
captures also this this change in be too
if the signal as s1 decreases from this
level to this level okay and so this
price that we charge is at least l1 and
that's it
okay in other words here this is a
change in veto due to the first guys
signal and we should be able to get at
least so much by looking just us at the
first guy signal and nothing else and
then oh sorry
there we go okay and in fact this holds
more generally assuming a certain
condition on the second derivative of
the value with respect to the buyers own
signal and anyone elses signal okay so
before I can move forward let me give a
quick comparison of where this result
stands relative to two other recent
results on the interdependent model so
one is the optimal auction do two timin
involve that I mentioned a little while
ago and another is an approximation we
are victory with preserves due to Lee so
we get a verse approximation factor than
either of these we require a single
crossing but then we we require a milder
condition on the value functions then
the optimal auction does but this one
doesn't require any condition on the
value functions and on the other hand
both of these mechanisms require a
number of conditions on the value
distributions and our approximation
doesn't require any assumptions on the
value distribution so this is one
strength of the approximation we can
extend this mechanism to other single
parameter settings so one natural
extension is to settings with a metroid
constraint so here we can simultaneously
serve sets of agents and i won't define
what Metroid's are most of you perhaps
know already but to natural examples of
Metroid's that arise our k unit auctions
and if you have a matching between
agents and items then this naturally
defines may Troi a Metroid over the sets
of agents that can
be matched two items on the other side
and so these are natural settings where
this might arise so for metroids our
mechanism is pretty much the same again
we in the first step we just reject
every agent independently with the
probability of one half and then for
whoever survives we run a generalized
VCG mechanism with preserves where we
first pick the set of we compute
everyone's values we serve the set that
has the maximum total value in it and
for every agent in that set we set an
optimal reserve price depending on all
of the information that we've seen so
far and that mechanism obtains a
constant factor approximation to the
optimal exposed I see revenue okay and
beyond metroids it turns out that
generalized BCG is no longer exposed I
see for a reason that's similar to why
it's not exposed I see four single crab
for settings that don't satisfy single
crossing and so again in this case we we
don't even know how to maximize expected
welfare presumably if we can figure that
out that ought to lead to good mechanism
for revenue as well so that's a that's a
natural open question so you conclude we
come up with a reasonably simple
constant factor approximation and the
strength of it is that we need mild
assumptions from the value functions we
don't need any assumptions on the value
distributions and so it greatly
simplifies know what we can do in the
setting okay thanks questions
you take a strip between yours and inch
work that's right that's right here yeah
so there's sort of incomparable yeah
they but I you know the when you have so
if the value function is the sort of
additive function over signals then both
of those second derivatives are zero so
yeah so that satisfies both of those
conditions anybody else's signal your
value is positive so your own signal is
positively correlated with your value
but the others don't have to be actually
I thought when you were conditioning on
the other value and talking about the
difference in between the required
that's be positive well if it's negative
then you really don't lose that term
yeah yeah so it doesn't have to be
positive you know it doesn't have to be
non decreasing
common value setting where each agent
gets the unknown value bus that's a
Gaussian noise it does in fact there
things should be even simpler for
revenue maximization that's right yeah
yeah that's right yeah it satisfy single
female any results for multinational
settings and also I I was confused about
the discussion of welfare what do we
know about weapon so what we know about
welfare is that under single crossing
generalized BCG is you know it exposed
maximizes welfare so it's optimal and
it's also exposed ife multi-dimensional
I haven't seen a reasonable model for it
so so I don't know you'd have to you
know come up with a reasonable model
first let's take the questions offline